The Epstein documentary dude, first of all,
I said this about pizza a long time ago,
about how I didn't think that it was a thing.
And I didn't think about how there were,
there were no pedophile rings in Hollywood and then people were,
what about Jeffrey Epstein?
Man is pretty quick case closed about the jeopardy of Britain. And I'm like,
yeah, dude, Jeffrey Epstein. Wasn't in Hollywood, man.
Jeffrey Epstein was a billionaire because he liked
move people's monies around and bought businesses and. And of course,
some people in Hollywood are bad just because some people are bad. You know,
how was like, I did the thing about pizza cake. People are like,
well that's because obviously Chris has something to hide. He's a PIDO. Well,
he's obviously got something. Cause I'm looking at him. Look at him,
look at him, look left, look at them, look left.
When he said it that's something.
He does somebody that does when they're a lawyer. And um,
but I saw the Jeffrey Epstein thing. And man, that dude looks a little bit,
I mean, that dude is a sociopath,
but the documentary on Netflix,
it was called like the Epstein files or whatever the it's called Epstein pure
money or some. It was called help.
Epstein healthy on the go is what it was Epstein facial scrubs grow.
And on the go green, good for the earth go li directed by Leah,
Michelle directed by Lee, Michelle Gellar. And um,
and uh, and dude,
and he molested so many women and girls and it's so
up. And dude,
the guy just didn't at the end of the documentary.
And this is all you can't ruin a documentary. I'm not ruining the documentary,
the da at the end of the thing, he was like, he moved his money around.
So the victims couldn't be paid. Like this guy was such a piece of.
And then he killed himself. The other thing too, that I disagree with.
A lot of people I want people are like, well, he killed himself.
He didn't get to live out his sentence. And that sucks.
He escaped the pain dude, that.
You know how probably painful killing yourself is probably hurts a lot too.
But also he didn't kill himself. Dude,
the cameras didn't work and the cops were sleeping.
The guards and Epstein hung himself. By the way, he didn't even,
I don't even think he jumped off something. I forget.
I think he just like tried to sit down really quickly and hang himself and broke
his neck, doing it and the coroner or whatever the they call them.
The forensics medical guy was like, um, no, this has never happened.
This is extremely rare.
And that means it didn't happen to Epstein got choked, dude.
So guy walks into the thing, paid a guard.
What a million, 3 million, $4 million.
These are billionaires that were jerking off on a massage
table with high school girls. You, you wouldn't cover it up for $10 million.
If you've got $95 billion, of course you would.
So they pay the bagel a guard, just so you know, I'm going to the,
I'm going to change your life.
You're going to be driving around and whatever the foreign you want,
your houses are going to have a many doors.
You're going to have a pool and you might even have to just let me get into that
and choke and police. And they go like this. Okay. Don't tell anybody.
And the guy says, why would I tell anybody? If I tell anybody,
then I got to go to jail too. And then they both jumped.
Like the Toyota commercials that they go, I left,
they jumped and they stopped paying and they were freeze frame with their legs
up. I love what you do for me.
That's what happened. And then, he goes, I'll be right back. And then it goes,
kink on opens the thing and goes
tiptoes near Jeffrey Epstein and goes like this. Remember me?
And then chokes him so hard that he broke his neck, man.
It's obviously what happened. And I'm no conspiracy theorist, dude.
I don't believe in any conspiracies. Oh,
chasms, razor or whatever the they say.
It's probably what the you think it is. But this,
this Jeffrey Epstein, somebody murdered this guy.
And dude, I'm a detective man.
I walk into the Epstein thing and I go like this. Well he,
he sat down into a news. Hmm. Something seems fishy.
Wow. Hmm. And you guys already think,
you know what happens? You think he killed himself? Hmm.
Jeffrey Epstein killed himself. I don't know. A little too.
Premature.
A little too premature of a decision for my liking.
[Inaudible].
And then put on sunglasses and leave dude out the window.
Man, that Epstein was trash. Huh?
There's other too. And that, that the documentary never told us who it was.
They just showed pictures. They said one thing about the Prince guy.
And then one thing about, uh, uh, bill Clinton.
And then they showed one picture of Chris Tucker. And I'm like,
Oh the duo who did it? I want to know the other people that were in it,
jerking off a massage tables with high school kid.
I want to know about these do the whole thing ended. And it was like,
I w w we all looked at each other and we were like, what the, man,
we don't get to know who else did it expose these?
All they said so many different times. They were like, Oh, well we don't know.
Uh, w well, yeah, there were tons of other high profile,
high profile people that, that, that, that tried to that me.
And when I was 14 and then, and then they were,
and they would like show people on a plane and you'd be like, Oh yeah,
there's Kevin Spacey. But did he do it? But say it, but did he do it,
but say it, Oh, there's a picture of Chris Tucker. But do it say it,
bill Clinton, did he do it? Say, Oh, he was on the Island. Oh,
he said he wasn't, but he was on the Island 26 times. Okay.
But did it do it say it because you're saying Jeffrey Epstein, did it tell us,
man, that's why I'm watching the documentary. I'm here for the juice beds.
I want to know, dude.
I want to know if Chris Taka was like,
Shut off color.
The worst impression of all time. Towelie
Why is it about Chris Ducker impression? Tally, dude,
I want to do it. If they had one scene where it's like,
and then Chris Tucker went like this, God you're supposed to come.
[inaudible] I would have been like, okay, worth it. The four episodes worth it.
You know how many pictures of the house they showed?
And the Jeffrey Epstein documentary.
So many pictures of them have a tracking shot of his West
Palm beach house. I don't give a about that. Show me more pictures in the plane.
You hinted at bill Clinton. You hinted at Kevin Spacey. Yeah. You said it,
the Prince dude did it. The Andrew Prince guy.
And you show one picture of Chris Ducker and you think that's a FYSEP.
Shimmy. My picks.
So more people who, who did
hit chicks, who are women now? Who did let me know, dude,
I would be that guy, man. I am a tattletale. Yeah,
dude. That's why I respect that 69 Kerr planche guy.
Cause he was just like, Oh. I'm caught.
Well, they were like, well, if you tell us and he was like, stop right there.
It was Dave. And they were like, okay,
well you're, you're free. Cool. I'll be rich now. Hell yeah.
Snitched. Oh, hell yeah. I snitched dude,
man. I think about that. How many bacons things so many times,
I know I've told you guys about that,
but when I was in a place called Bergeys and locking you out,
I would go and I would get the tuna melt and I would say, Hey,
can I get bacon on it? And the guy would always say, sure, how many bacons?
And I, I think about that every time,
how many bacons and I cooked bacon every morning because my girl won't do it.
And I make how many bacons through your eight? Three or four?
Why did I say eight? Oh, cool. Good. Cool. Got it tomorrow. All good. Oh,
that's all good. Did someone call the doctor? I have a tumor.
I said eight instead of four sauce. All good after three, by the way. Oh.